[Musique]
une légende tibétaine raconte qu'un jour
le dieu vishwakarma descendit du ciel et
déposa sur le mont gfl la plus ancienne
représentation d'une divinité
[Musique]
c'est la statue d'un géant dont le
sourire hermétique contient l'expression
de toutes les idoles du monde
[Musique]
c'est ce géant ce sont les anciens
astronautes cité dans les mythologies du
monde entier
[Musique]
deux rangs différents ces géants sont
appelés hanouna qui par les sumériens
elohim par les hébreux théo y parler
grec d'eva par les indiens et par
d'autres non selon l'endroit
doté d'une technologie très avancée ces
géants sont six ans mâles et femelles
leur espérance de vie est millénaire et
il utilise habituellement la
modification génétique et le clonage
[Musique]
ayant besoin de main d'oeuvre pour
l'heure quand les géants produisent pour
un certain temps des créatures étranges
des sous produits de tests génétiques
qu'il finisse par éliminer quand ils
réalisent leurs meilleurs produits
terrestre l'homme il en clown des
milliers et produisent enfin la femme
pour que ces nouvelles créatures se
multiplient tout seul
[Musique]
disposant maintenant de travailleurs les
géants se partagent le monde
formant chacun une nation mais comme
leur caractère et belliqueux ils se font
la guerre pour des questions de
territoire
les premiers humains eux vénère ces
géants qui les ont créés et les prennent
pour des dieux mais le rapport n'est pas
cordiale
c'est dieu assure la nourriture comme
tout éleveur mais traite les humains
comme du bétail et frappe
les désobéissants
[Musique]
dans cette équipe d'astronautes
explorateurs chaque géant est un
technicien spécialisé dans une
discipline spécifique
[Musique]
il y a le dieu du feu vulcain qui
forgent les foudre de zeus le dieu du
vent eole le dieu de l'eau neptune le
dieu de la médecine asklepios le dieu de
la guerre mars et les autres
en mission loin de leur planète c'est
dieu aime se relâcher son livre en de
bière d'orge
la bière est inventée en egypte par le
dieu osiris qui la fabrique dans un
temple caché à l'embouchure du nil pour
garder le secret la bière arrive à sumer
ou la ds in and à l'offre aux prêtres
dans son temple du rugby
en sicile la déesse grecque demeter
cultive l'orge elle-même et produit la
série vie siens la bière vénéré par les
romains la bière est déclarée monopole
d'état par le pharaon s'est dit son fils
ramsès deux ans prescrit un tribut de
milan fort chaque année pour le temple
de dendérah demeure de la déesse mère à
tort
à babylone le code d'hammourabi conçoit
pour la bière le premier plafonds
tarifaires de l'histoire
en plus de boire c'est dieu adore inhalé
du gras fumée
pour entrer en contact avec lui il
suffit d'allumer un feu aidés sacrifier
un animal attirés par l'odeur les dieux
arrive un manque ablement et récompenses
réseaux francs jusqu'à éliminer leurs
adversaires parmi les géants femmes
toutes de haut rang les plus célèbres
sont la déesse sumérienne istar les
déesse égyptienne à tort et isis la
déesse grecque
athena et tant d'autres une règle sur
leur territoire en instituant le
matriarcat
l'année du rpt 364 jours et est divisé
en 13 mois lunaire de 28 jours comme le
cycle menstruel la succession au trône
se fait par voie féminine et au 13e mois
la reine sacrifie un roi d'où la
superstition du nombre 13
dans le matriarcat les femmes sont
protégés par une très forte conception
de la chasteté tous les cultes dédiés
aux déesses vierge jusqu'à la madone
[Musique]
parmi les ds la ds mère est la plus
vénérée son image est la trinité lunaire
avec la lune croissante de la déesse
vierge
athena la lune pleine de la déesse
aphrodite et la lune déclinante de la
déesse héra
[Musique]
cette trinité est symbolisée par le
masque de la gorgone une femme coiffée
de serpents qui effraie ceux qui la
regardent cette attention défrayer vient
de ce qu'un jour la vierge
athena subi une mésaventure ne portant
qu'un bouclier sur lequel est peinte la
gorgone athena a besoin d'une armure et
rend donc exit odieux vulcain dans sa
fonderie de l'etna pour qu'ils lui en
fabrique une
vulcain lui portait déjà un regard
concupiscent sur la jeune vierge et il
profite de l'occasion pour se lancer sur
elle prête à la violer
mais athéna l'air son bouclier et la
gorgone et frais à tel point vulcain
elle réussit à s'échapper
[Musique]
depuis les jeunes filles méditerranéenne
porte une tunique de chasteté sur
laquelle est peinte la gorgone pour
terroriser les hommes qui attentent à
leur virginité en europe le matriarcat
décline
quand un peuple hyperboréens kit donne
actuelle estonie et arrive à la
méditerranée envahissant les îles entre
les mer egée est et ionienne ce peuple
ce sont les anciens grecs au maire
raconte les gestes de leurs dieux les
théories mais les événements qu'il cite
ont eu lieu en baltique et non pas en
grèce où il n'ya pas de soleil à minuit
ni de glace
cette invasion apporte le culte solaire
masculin
le roi prend les pleins pouvoirs les
transmet l'héritage office mal dans le
roi meurt une cérémonie renouvelle sa
vie pendant une journée
un substitut règne à sa place et le soir
après avoir consommé son dernier repas
il est sacrifiée
[Musique]
les chairs du substitut et du roi sont
alors manger et leur sang est éparpillée
sur les champs pour les féconder en inde
dans le festin liturgique du chakra
pouge à 12 participants sous la conduite
d'un mètre boivent le sens de la déesse
shakti et mange la chair du dieu shiva
dans la même cérémonie eucharistique que
la dernière cène de jésus de cette
ancienne tradition s'inspire le
sacrifice de la pâques chrétiennes par
la nécessité d'une mort afin que la vie
se renouvelle parmi les dieux qui
meurent s'offrant en sacrifice pour
ressurgir dans une nouvelle vie il y a
le dieu égyptien osiris le dieu
babyloniens tamuz le dieu maya kenza
colt et tant d'autres jusqu'au christ le
dieu rédempteur des chrétiens
[Musique]
les performances de ces dieux géants qui
ne meurt jamais et qui vont et viennent
du ciel à bord de chars bruyant font
fantasmer les hommes qui imagine alors
un monde divin où tout est possible
il invente alors les miracles le paradis
l'enfer
la résurrection la réincarnation et même
la vie éternelle
mais le dieu supérieur de la bible les
lots hymne et lyon n'est pas d'accord
avec ces élucubrations humaine
[Musique]
il affirme que les dieux meurt comme les
hommes et les animaux et que tout être
vivant disparaîtra dans le lait en car
il n'y a rien avant chaque vie ni rien
après
la bible est un ensemble de textes
rédigés par les hébreux après leur exil
à babylone dans ce carrefour de cultures
les hébreux rencontre des disciples de
zoroastre et reste que si convaincus par
leur notion du dieu unique qu'ils
décident de fonder une religion
hébraïque monothéistes
[Musique]
les hébreux ont déjà un lieu les lots y
milhavet et ont confiance en lui
y avait les a jadis guidée de sumer
jusqu'à la terre promise et ne les
abandonnera pas maintenant dans l'exil
babylonien en effet il ne s'écoule que
le temps d'une génération et les hébreux
reviennent en judée reconstruisent le
temple de jérusalem est constitue leur
religion monothéiste
[Musique]
les hébreux savent bien que les elohim
sont plusieurs
mais ils proclament y avait comme dieu
unique créateur du ciel de la terre et
de l'homme et composent la bible
hébraïque manipulant leurs anciens
textes qu'ils adaptent à la version
monothéistes
[Musique]
dans leur bible dieu a créé l'homme à
partir d'une poignée d'argile cependant
la création de la femme est beaucoup
plus laborieuse
[Musique]
dieu doit à anesthésier adam lui
extraire des cellules souches et suturé
la coupure pour obtenir rêve alors que
le lieu unique fait surface en palestine
en grèce
à l'époque les dieux sont signés et les
érudits grecque explique le corps la
psyché et la mort de façon rationnelle
en même temps au népal
bouda perçoit l'homme comme un esprit
éternelle qui vit différentes étapes
dont l'une est la condition humaine en
chine
lao tseu prêche la confiance dans la
nature et dans le tas au l'equilibre
parfait qui soutient l'univers
[Musique]
les liens qui s'entrecroisent entre les
traditions du monde sont très nombreux
les yaks chaque chinois correspondent
aux satire de la mythologie européenne
les bodhisattva indien correspond aux
anges et aux saints chrétiens bouddha
est représenté comme un dieu grec et
jésus est un énième dieu qui se fait
homme
[Musique]
en effet trois mille ans avant
jésus-christ plusieurs dieux se sont
incarnés en sommes le dieu indien j'eus
krishna
né d'une vierge par transfert divin
échappe au massacre des enfants prêche
le bien
moeurs ressuscite et utilise sa
technologie pour accomplir des miracles
en grèce le dieu dionysos visite le
royaume des morts transmute l'eau en vin
meurt et ressuscite
l'egypte aussi à son dieu qui se fait
homme
c'est aux russes fils de la vierge
isis déesse égyptienne de la lune
enveloppée dans un manteau bleu
constellé des toiles il naît le 25
décembre dans une grotte sa naissance
est annoncée par une étoile et
l'événement est attendu par trois rois
aux russes reçoit or encens et myrrhe et
baptisé à l'âge de 30 ans par annuler le
bâtisseur qui sera décapité est suivi
par douze disciples
lutte pendant 40 jours dans le désert
contre 7 le méchant des livres des
sermons moeurs ressuscite
après trois jours et utilise sa
technologie pour ressusciter l asa russe
et marcher sur l'eau représenté par une
croix formant la triade de divine
égyptienne au russe est cité comme le
messie est le fils oint de dieu aux
alentours de l'an zéro y avait encore
les lots hymne du peuple hébraïque
mais avec l'occupation romaine de la
palestine
il craint d'être chassés par les elohim
des romains plus puissant que lui il
lourd dit alors
une rébellion juive contre les romains
il ordonne à son archange gabriel de
greffer l'adn elohim sur des femmes
juives afin que celle ci génère des
sommes supérieures
[Musique]
dans l'ancien testament y avait avait
déjà envoyé un gabriel chez des femmes
juives et elle avait enfanté les gémeaux
comme les naissances multiples des
accouchements in vitro
[Musique]
maintenant y avait ordonne à gabriel
d'intervenir sur la cousine de la vierge
marie elisabeth qui génère jean baptiste
et sur la vierge marie qui génère deux
gémeaux y est choix et thomas le temps
d'une génération c'est cool et la
rébellion juive est prêt
jean baptiste recrutent les agitateurs
les lions par le sermon du baptême les
choix les entraîne au combat contre les
troupes romaines et son camarade pierre
est chargé des financements des choix
est aussi appelée barabbas qui veut dire
fils de dieu car les rebelles savent que
c'est un envoyé du dieu yahvé et quand
jean baptiste est décapité
ces choix qui continue le combat
rassemblant des foules et couvrant ainsi
de nouveaux adhérents
[Musique]
cependant les actes de pierre inquiète
les rebelles
pierre du surplace un couple qui ne lui
a pas donnée l'entièreté de ses biens et
cela effraie les rebelles et surtout
judas qui avertit les romains
un régiment d'auxiliaires syrien à la
solde de rome 500 soldats armés vont
alors arrêtez de dangereux chef rebelle
gisha barabbas
son j'aime au dôme à lui ressemble
tellement que judas doit t'embrasser
yeshua pour que les soldats ne se trompe
pas
[Musique]
le préfet de judée ponce pilate
condamnent ses choix barabbas à la
crucifixion comme les insurgés mais les
rebelles attendent que les soldats
partent port on peut les gardiens et
enlève yeshua encore vivants de la croix
le cache dans une tombe privé et la nuit
l'amène tant mieux si la répression
romaine devient alors semblant jérusalem
est sur le point d'être détruite et les
rebelles sont des libres très anciens
ayant échappé au bûcher des gars de
rouge mao tsé toung atteste que les
choix par abbas de réfugiés au sud est
et demeure pour une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
songez mot dôme a connu pour le récit du
doigt dans la plaie s'échappe en inde et
son tombeau existe encore les portugais
débarqué au sud de l'inde au 16ème
siècle
en témoigne
[Musique]
face à l'échec de sa rébellion les lots
il y avait disparaît pour toujours et la
classe sacerdotale juive craint d'être
dissoute par les romains elle conçoit
alors une nouvelle religion juive plus
approprié à l'audience grecque romaine
et en confie la réalisation à un érudit
juifs romains
le notable paul de tarse
mais paul est un visionnaire il choisit
comme dieu de cette nouvelle religion le
juif fils de dieu y est choix barabbas
condamné 50 ans auparavant par ponce
pilate
c'est un rebelle
les romains ne l'accepteront jamais
comme un dieu alors paul un coup de
génie
il a inventé deux personnages distincts
les chats et barabas
par abbas el rebelles libérés par me
lapp et yeshua est le nouveau dieu
martyrs qui se sacrifie pour sauver
l'humanité
paul utilise la tradition orientale pour
renforcer la religion commissionnée mais
quand les juifs s'aperçoivent qui veut
faire de yeshua un nouveau lieu
ils l'accusent de blasphème et veulent
l'emprisonner pierre veut même le tuer
mais paul s'échappe par la mer
se réfugier andres et poursuivant son
idée il change tout d'abord le nom
yeshua en jésus l'associant au dieu grec
zeus
puis toujours confiant dans l'efficacité
des traditions orientales il le complète
dans jésus christ pour l'associer aux
dieux indien j'eus krishna enfin
s'inspirant de la triade divine paul
fait d'un mélange des vies de krishna
d'horus et de dionysos et compose ainsi
la vie de jésus christ comme elle est
décrite dans les évangiles rien à voir
avec les souabes à rabat ce qui lui a
bien existé
[Musique]
paul ne s'arrête pas là il remanie la
bible hébraïque afin qu'elle annonce la
venue du christ il invente l'éternité le
péché originel l'envoie sur terre de
jésus
son sacrifice afin qu'il expie les
péchés du monde et sa résurrection
[Musique]
paul réalise un bon travail puisque ce
mélange des plus efficaces traditions
orientales touche une multitude de coeur
en effet sa version donne naissance à la
religion chrétienne et la foi de ses
fidèles est si forte que les
polythéistes e romain après avoir
persécuté les chrétiens embrasse le
christianisme et se font même baptisé
toutefois vers l'an 300 un débat anime
les érudits zeb l'évêque chrétiens de
césar et en palestine crois que dieu a
inspiré la bible mais le philosophe grec
porphyre n'est pas d'accord porphyre
soutient que la bible est une copie
trompeuse du manuscrit de geron balle
le successeur de moïse dans ce très
ancien ouvrages il n'y a pas de dieu ni
d'éternité mais uniquement des
événements liés aux rapports entre
certains extraterrestre venu du ciel et
certains chefs du peuple hébraïque
[Musique]
les anciens textes indiens chinois et de
l'amérique centrale site le même type de
rapport mais la pensée conventionnelle
occidentales considèrent ces écrits
comme des fantasmes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec l'instruction publique
l'accessibilité aux bibliothèques les
traductions moderne l'ingénierie
génétique les ordinateurs internet et
surtout avec la rationalité moderne nous
pouvons discerner l'authentic dufau de
toute cette histoire
[Musique]
nous découvrons alors que les textes
sacrés actuels sont des copies
frauduleuses d'anciens écrits surtout
sumériens que chaque religion a adapté à
ses propres exigences
[Musique]
le comble est que ces adaptations
prennent de belliqueux explorateurs
extraterrestres pour des véritables
dieux spirituel prônant même leur
adoration au vatican
les études comparées des anciens écrits
et la dernière traduction de la bible
fonds abdiqué un pape et oblige son
successeur le pape françois a affirmé
qu'il ne faut pas prendre la
résurrection de jésus comme un événement
historique mais comme un acte de foi
le clergé catholique défend alors ses
privilèges millénaire et accusent le
pape françois d'hérésie pour ces
propositions contraires à la vérité
divine mais les scientifiques modernes
comprennent ce que leurs anciens
prédécesseurs ne pouvait même pas
imaginer comme les navettes spatiales
et la manipulation génétique beaucoup de
notions sont aujourd'hui plus clair à la
lumière de ces faits un esprit rationnel
pourrait donc avancé que jusqu'à la
preuve du contraire le monde spirituel
des religions n'est qu'une blague et que
l'histoire des extraterrestres devenus
des dieux dans le souvenir des hommes
est la seule qui offre une explication
rationnelle aux énigmes de la
protohistoire et peut-être même aux
origines de l'homme
enfin quoiqu'il en soit cette épopée qui
nous tient en haleine de bout en bout
c'est notre passé lointain un passé
plein de surprises dont les
rebondissements sont toujours
passionnantes comme les coups de théâtre
[Applaudissements]